yes we couldn't take all employees
with us so and now we can only take a
limited number with us
no matter how much if you had taken the top package
even then and of
course i wanted that how do i get them
from namely the oldest employees
namely the top management  namely
I behave yes it's just unfair yes
we said we're not going
to Frankfurt nobody yes I do
n't need it for my ego
to stand there on the floor and make a sound
but what we did is we have
a video wall  uh put a big
videotape in the office there built a
small desk in front of it
then took a picture of the Deutsche Börse
behind it, which was branding everywhere,
so our designers where about home to go
said others simply rang the bell in front of it, yes
, but they also photographed it that way  that if
you can see that we
faked it a little bit exactly and
at the same time we, um, we
also have Wä  We built them with a home to go
logo and so on where you could do
that and, funnily enough, we also
erected home to go branded trucks in front of
the stock exchange, so
we drove them around the stock exchange,
the city of Frankfurt
kindly also has this pedestrian zone  there,
er,
with our partner, with whom we
did it, with the trucks, there, er, freed up
and then
there was a big home to go truck right in front of the stock exchange,
so where because we had driven
them around anyway, we had driven around our office
several times and there too
to say stop ne stood with it loud engine
and and and horns then in front of the stock exchange
that also glass we are there although we did it in
Berlin fun fact after
this podcast the share price of the
company that founded my guest rose by
over
20%.  Madness, however, the share is
still relatively small market cap about
300 million, but he still takes
on a giant and says he can build the
better or at least alternative
airbn, there is the story of
Patrick Andrea and home to
go, where the whole thing was already recorded at
the end of the 22nd century  that's why all statements
refer to 22 an exciting story
hometogo vs Airbnb the story of
Patrick André let's go tell me
you didn't
get around to founding it now because of the rock time but
started much earlier with some kind of
tag affinity yeah well I've always
been since I was young  I need my
father persuaded that we can finally get a computer when we
were 12
and um then very interested
in all technical things optimized
what um what concerns the computer
and then at some point got into
programming and noticed but I wouldn't call it
hardcore programming  so
my strength was in terms of because i
so patient was and is always had to
build programs then you have to
compile it and then at the end you had to
wait somehow had a runtime error and
then came HTML
I got to know HTML when I
think 1.2 or something like that was HTML and I was
very busy with it, it was also
easier  you can just press F5 in the browser
yes, right in the children's room in Hanover
, when I was around 13 or 14 years old, at some point and um
yes, I was very busy with it
and at some point I saw
that the internet was just starting back then, I was born in
81, it's like that in the 90s and
uhm that was very exciting because then the
local internet service provider
didn't necessarily run Telekom but
someone who offered the local internet was
looking for someone who did web design at the time
, today you would
say that it's programming design and
maybe product without ship, of course,
a completely different one  Level means that it
will take place today, but I
just went there and then said  I
apply there when I was 16, of course I
didn’t have a portfolio, but
I had already built everything I could design with
Photoshop and so on and I
simply completely
pre-built my own website and brought
it with me and they called me and said we
would like to do it with you and
then I worked there for
about a year and a half alongside school and
at some point I noticed how much money they
actually earn with me and then I started my
own business a bit
and did it as a freelancer, above
all for American
customers, alongside school as a student, yes,
exactly  and then in the end you've already
earned 1000 or 100,000 not that much
but you've already earned a bit of money
and I put most of that into
shares okay yes that's why
I can already buy them then
somehow
even more speculatively I would say
probably back then yes so  it was
a bit of a dot-com thing then
and there  n I've also taken part
in the dot-com bubble with
topics that just saw you yourself,
ne so a student, relatively speaking, but
it was still interesting
to learn how such a crisis develops and
why things work,
but then you're still like that
when school was over then
you came to study law in a relatively classic way you
even tried law at the end so that's
a surprising
turn of events not so surprising at all
I noticed when I offered these web design or web programming topics you always notice it
usually comes  a customer to you and
tells you I had or at least something like that back then
yes I would like to
have a new website design
somehow and then of course he doesn’t just want to
see one version but somehow
two or three and it was always maybe for me
too  out of natural
youthful carelessness at that time
always so very bad when my when
my V  ariante that I found very good was
not chosen, but then
maybe the one where I
maybe the top variant where I spent a day
or two days or three days or
maybe a week on
it and then something that
I could do as a second or third
alternative  I offered the version that was
then chosen, above all, because
I still had to implement it
afterwards, so I didn't just
design, I
also built the websites afterwards
and that was always, well I don't want to
say annoying, but it was uncomfortable when
you  Of course a problem ran in
that you might not have had with the
top version that you thought yourself
and in the end it was
relatively clear to me what I saw okay
actually
I had already seen before that I
was programming in classic
programming that is now
Studying computer science would not necessarily
be what would make me happy,
I could digit  Al his, however, was
never the one who
always got an A from an art
class and accordingly
I also knew that studying design
although I think it is very important to me
, the topic is aesthetics in general
but
design has nothing what would be
would make me happy and then there was
exactly this third topic that makes the
decision about what
ultimately goes into the product or
what the business
or risky
entrepreneur decision and when
I was thinking about it at the time, well, at the
end of my school days  what I want to
study and you took a look at it in
Germany
, of course, as I said, a
limited and maybe a
bit naïve view of the
time, but you saw that
it was essentially business administration and law that
people studied that made the decision
meet in German companies so
mine  Parents both studied law, of
course you also created a
certain family affinity with the
subject, because otherwise you can’t
try it, yes, exactly, I then
studied law, but I also studied business administration on the side
, so I got a diploma
from them, but I also learned about business administration  did your
first state exam with VB yes
so almost even good yes but and then did my
doctorate and then also did the second
state exam with the VW
great law firms and then work
for several 100 € a day
yes well yes exactly
had some offers yes  I had
also
worked briefly for a
law firm alongside my doctorate, but my
boss, my partner at the time, said
you could start here, but I
think you have more talent, something
nice
to say is actually almost not
for here  you or I would
so she wanted actually she
would like to take me  but she knew that
I wanted to do something else because in
the meantime I had already done
an internship at European founders in Munich during my studies or during my studies
thing that brought everything back
together
I asked a little bit if I
understood the stock market and other things
and then it started and then it started and at the time it
felt like a long conversation with Mark because he
wanted to persuade me to start right away
and who is also a lawyer from the
Apprenticeship and somehow
not doing the presentation and
not finishing the doctoral thesis but
I was told I want to finish that first and I like to
work for
you on projects yes and then of course I
mainly worked on
Rocket projects and that's
why I'm  then in the end came around
24 and so the furniture company
exactly that yes e  A portfolio company was
that was founded exactly and
there was not the boss but what exactly you managed
business development or
at the beginning I came to expand the
marketplace on the business side
but funnily enough I was still in the
department and then I did
it  next to the doctor when he
started to build up the marketplace as a
business song and then when I was old I went
back to around 24 with a little break for the second state exams
yes exactly and then I
met people who you can also see from the podcast
here as more precisely  higher
could at least know all Nils regge
who now does other things but has
built and financed very successful companies and he
has already
called Casamundo a holiday real estate
brokerage exactly and I think how it
was because I was here two years ago it's been doing
it for so long  So things are a
bit different from here, but back then
he just did something like that and uh you have it
met and he told you did it again
then well we did
so in the end it was like that
I already got to know that I was still working
for Rocket, uh, it's
essential, but that's why one of
his companies in which he was involved was
interested  had to entice me away as
CEO yes I didn't find it that exciting for me at the time
because I wanted to build something new yes and
um how should I get along very well
and we founded a third
co-founder, Wolfgang Heigel
sold to kayaks so then the
Americans must be American
models in the end what belongs to
booking so the others were your
two Corinna if you now after Nils
and Wolfgang were already multimillionaires
you have to ask them
but in the end in the end
I came together and we
then thought about what could make sense
yes and Nils he said
again you already had success  ahrungen
ferienhausbereich wolfgang has already built
a meta-search engine for wings
at kayak sales was then
managing director europe the europe
business as here in the bust size
and then we just thought about
what we can actually do together
and since we all
don’t have this personal problem ourselves  only
ultimately saw the market
situation but also had this personal
problem
finding a really decent holiday home
and comparing them said okay
why does a meta search actually make me
as the original
business model we
started with at the very beginning of the
market entry  most are for this
market if you look at the holiday home
market, this classic
holiday home market in which we are active
, i.e. classic holiday homes on the Baltic Sea
North Sea in Italy in the mountains for
skiing, i.e. for holidays with
the family, then you can see that the
mark  t is again a separate market in
each individual country, so if we now take
Germany, for example, the
German market is more fragmented than
the global flight market or the global
hotel market, yes, and of course you have that,
and the same goes
for France and the USA  and with
that you have an incredible opportunity
to create value to first
unite everything on one platform that was
the basic idea of ​​hometogo yes it will be
founded we said we will
create a platform where we will
ultimately bring all holiday homes and
holiday apartments together on one
platform than as  Goal
and we have also achieved that, so
if you look at holiday homes and
holiday apartments, we are the
largest platform in the world and then we
said in the next step how or in
our plan how do we develop the
business further but basically the
idea comes from the  market is
just so confusing and
ger  Goodbye you as a customer don't have a chance to
somehow compare objects on different
sites,
so maybe it wasn't tried well,
but I mean you can see
casamunde by Nils or
various others, I don't even remember
what it was called because there were a few
names back then, so there were quite a few  in the market
where you could look like that, well I think
I think in the end there was a
different business
yes that is also a partner of e.g.
but there was already a lot there so exactly
completely somehow had a new idea
yes but the idea was different in
that way  In the end we positioned ourselves again as an overall
aggregator for the entire
market, so we said we
club in Casamundo and FeWo directly in
Booking.com a lot of small
administrators and providers on one
platform so that you can really
see which property is there  on
the different platforms on the
different sides and
can get an overview on one side
about what  there is everything on the market
it would be offering everything and also at what
price it was like that the
classic meta the classic meta
are looking for the approach
yes and then we have over time and
that was relatively clear to us when
we founded it but over  time
seen this is of course provider gives
the technologist the meta search
works so someone searches on
your site and then you
link them out to another
website at the end where the transaction
then takes place then you get a
commission exactly from this transaction
in turn,
saying paid transactions carries out exactly
so from the partner of the time,
so you buy traffic or via SEO
or search or whatever and then
there's a click-out to another
brokerage platform and
you'll get it again from their brokerable platform
been a part,
but for us it was very, very
important that we
build a marketplace out of hometogo
because you have  quite a lot of partners if
you send someone there with a click
on as you say,
whose website may not be
the Converse the most conversion-
optimized, yes, and of
course they have disadvantages in your overall search in terms of
competition, although
they are often a smaller
provider  completely offered exactly they are
not loved by you and not
displayed above because they do not provide any commission
yes or they simply
do not comment that is one of the
commission the other okay
so if you have higher conversion
you have to pay less and in the
end it was  then it is very important for us
that we convert our model into a marketplace model
, yes, that means that the
transaction takes place for the most part on the
marketplace, so the customer
searches, finds and pays on home to
go and is no longer laid out and
that is now e.g. in Germany  whatever
whatever so our so or roof store in
Germany Austria S  Switzerland
is now also about 80
percent or almost 80 percent of the
transactions that take place on the
marketplace and the rest is then where
there are still click-outs more or
less as a kind of
advertising and that works very,
very well because it  It helps the white partners
to be competitive on the platform, but at the same time it is of course also
interesting for us because we can
also help with our technical solutions
and are closer to the customer
in the overall relationship from
hometogo now to the customer who travels, you see,
but and that  is actually the
exciting thing about what you
can solve with technology in this case,
just the booking process, i.e.
the booking on your own
platform and this
marketplace is for us we have over
60,000 partners who we
meanwhile associate with
over  15 million offers and of
course they all have to be on one platform  m
make it consistent, so they analyze
pictures, for example, understand what's on
the pictures, we can make the
pictures more beautiful, we understand the
whole topic, so that's about 3.5 billion
pictures and we can
really understand what actually
happens with the objects and them
prepare that for you as a user you have
a consistent experience on home to
go so everything is one
hand we have a lot of different
and landlords and so behind exactly and you
get the best overview so if
you are really looking for normal Sylt or something
then you will  you see that's you
don't have this selection and luxury
segment a bit down anywhere for everything
cheaper exactly we offer something for everyone
for every category but also for
every purse and especially if
you look at what
is ultimately also concerned with price-performance
I think it's different relatively
quickly if you use home to
go
okay so it h  At that time the idea was
born that to do it like this first
as an abitrat model then you have it as a
marketplace with which is
probably now relatively complex
because then providers who actually
don’t plan to be sold on the
Internet with them you had to back
then  individually on the phone
explaining how they are now listed
here and so on it always depends
I think at the beginning yes but
meanwhile we are of course very
popular so actually we work together
with everyone in the market in the end
is not listed with us on the platform
yes the apartment they are
there they don't exist with you no that's
always a bit
don't get me wrong a wrong
assumption by many of many people
yes that what you still find erwin how
maybe no other platform is
available yes and he how work  with
Airbnb in a different
way but I'll be right back
Erwin how he reduced his marketing
as part of Corona
yes and accordingly they were once
on our site but were
no longer on the site
the inventory what is on Airbnb but it
is not necessarily
unique because  the landlords say I
put it in everywhere I have
several platforms on which I am active anyway
but what percentage is Airbnb
inventory goes somewhere else and how
much is
I can say yes I don’t have your
data and um I’ll say old ones
Of course I ca
n't comment on the business relationship because that was it, but
the feeling is that the problem is with
all the things, they're often
unique and then you can only put them in once,
that's not making me
a room
or two and then somehow individual rooms  he just like the
room full why should they
put it
in another way usually so we have e.g. that’s
why i mean wi  We have
a
business relationship with Erwin in a different way because
we build our marketplace Software
Service and subtion Service is
ultimately solutions or solutions
for the for the inventory side for
our partners who supply us with inventory
and for example a  The solution to
this
is called smoubu, yes, that is a piece of
software if, for example, you now have your
property
on Airbnb on booking on home to go
on FeWo direkt that then helps you
to synchronize the calendar and prices
and of course I’ll say
the dates or the  Data quality on the
other platforms makes it better and
at the same time enables you as the provider of
the holiday home that you
don’t get a double booking or something like that,
so if your house is booked on rbb, it’s
probably launched a bit in your own interest,
so of course it’s easier for
the holiday home owners and landlords in the evening
you then have a lot more inventory to do  about it
in access or visibility
so for you that would otherwise maybe
just be somewhere else the the customer can
decide for himself which portals
he is active on from Smoo it is not so that he
is then automatically on home to go
sure, yes,
that's really a software, that's
a pure subs, so purely subscription 4,
that means the customer can ultimately
decide for himself what he chooses
and is also a software that we
bought around the marketplace
because it made sense to us  that
to expand for people that make the
topic smooth yes we do
n't publish but already a few a few
thousand no no so you now mean
from from people who use
the system yes that's a lot yes
so if you
if you it  would break out is a
very nice sitting business what
we have around the marketplace
and we really do that so someone uses that
by one  two holiday homes
belong, so it's usually
people with a few holiday homes,
but not someone who now manages a thousand
holiday homes or so many
people who really own several holiday homes as a business
and also rent them out, I
would have the feeling you have your own from
time to time or  you're just a professional
you kind of have hundreds of things like that and something in
between there's everything in between so
it's really like that there are people who there
are individually
someone who rents out their private holiday home
that they use themselves maybe
also rented out so and then
you have on the  On the other hand, people who
may have started out like this
and then either add something new themselves
or the neighbor says you ca
n’t mean renting,
so a lot of these small
agencies and administrators
actually started out that way with their
own
house and then always have  get more other
customers because they saw it
me with but it is the main group of
customers so people with two
to ten holiday homes or for that
so for this software yes and generally
and generally we have all sizes so
we have a bit of really
individuals or providers with
a house to manage the 30
40  Manage 50,000 properties, yes,
we call the property managers
holiday home managers or agencies, and
we also work with, for example
, booking
or Feo directly, which belongs
to Expedia together
Immediately
explode in terms of sales,
I think Airbnb
is first of all from a slightly different
market, so if you
are looking for a classic holiday home then you have to
go through hometogo, yes, and
I don't think that Airbnb, so to speak, is
blocking the way for us [music] to grow  yes, you can
see something when you look at
our numbers  And as
Q3 figures have just been published, we have
grown in sales by 60% over the years, so
I think you're doing something this year, I'm planning 140. We
have our guidance, yes, we've
been on the stock exchange since last year, which means
what we expect, we have this  Year
corrected twice upwards yes
so that increases sales growth because we
assume that we will make more
sales than originally thought at the beginning of the
year and we will make
between 141 and 146 million
sales this year that is internal rate ne that
means exactly the commission so that means
the largest, the traveled or what you
pay for the trip is well
over 1.5 billion
what is paid for it by customers and
who are horny the result is now
also transparent that we are
both about bigger still loss of
20  Millions this year 20 to 25, yes
, but we also have that twice
, lower loss than originally
assumed  beginning of the year and the
main costs are then marketing costs,
so you have the inventory
on it and people would have to get in there somehow.
Marketing is a big block,
definitely
preliminary talks with our daughters, yes,
what does marketing mean, personnel costs
and a bit of the hope that
one  Day-to-day marketing can make up
so maybe said in the corona crisis
marketing makes up now and we
are known big enough we no
longer do marketing exactly so in the
end you always have to do marketing in
one way or another yes  It is
now performance marketing or whether it
is paid or whether it is via brand
or other channels, but of course what we
see is that the
proportion of customers who have already
booked with hometogo is
correspondingly cheaper or free of charge.
Customers who come back directly to  the site is
getting bigger
and
bigger  ßer will be and accordingly he holds a
share in sings yes and that of course creates
a large
item in marketing and ultimately creates
efficiencies which then also because our
goal is to be profitable next year
I already knew that
we haven't rethought it now  because it is
now
opportune yes profitable and that was
also our plan we
went public here last year
we said 223 we want to be
profitable so we are also very, very
happy about how we saw the
development this year as
well  that we were able to further reduce our
forecast of the loss this year
and thus in the end make less loss
at the end of the year than we
thought at the beginning of the year
put it in, people put their inventory
in your place, yes, I have the
same feeling there too  Airbnb, you
go there automatically not only as a tenant but
also as a landlord.
You already have this market so that
someone who has a holiday
that automatically I'm on it with you yes,
that's nicer yes, um,
if you're in the  German market that
looks at, so our first market is
the roof market, so to speak, that means the
German or Austrian Swiss
who goes on vacation, so
I’m not talking about the roof in the market, I’m not talking about the
objects, but really about
the demand market, like now, so where the where
the people  they come here
later and then you ca
n't really avoid home to go, yes, and
if you
look at it, that's of course what
always automatically drives providers to
us, as I said at the beginning,
yes  you briefly talked about
that a moment ago that you obviously
have to convince people you're completely
new but don't call it a brand yet
meanwhile, the professional
administrators of
course all know us, and uh, you can
see whenever we did
TV advertising or something, for example
, at the beginning there were also the
private and smaller agencies
who really wanted to go to the site and
now it is  actually completely normal
that we that we have a lot of people
who want to be on the platform with us what
is the ideal holiday home so
if I could now if you could
wish for one yourself it
was proof that we are always occupied all year round
and there is  the best
prices what would that be
so I think that's very
individual yes I think what the what
the best holiday home is very good but
there is most often where you
say if I stole more of it
I could always get through it for me
quite clearly because we are so
prominent in the roof market, what is very classic in the roof market
is the North Sea, Baltic Sea, yes,
and the Baltic Sea is beautiful  ject that
always works yes means then there is a town
or an area or something on which that
or somehow yes e.g. that but also
everything around Timmendorfer Strand and so
on yes so a very classic
Baltic Sea coast is e.g. what exactly
how much how many people in
then it's normal for families to be around four
yes, um, but that and then a holiday home, well, a
classic holiday home that always works
is there in the
street so what that really depends
on for us for us because the
customers who are on
our side are so different you have people
who say to me it is above all
important that I have a holiday home
where I have complete peace and quiet and
no one around me there are people
who somehow want to be close to me then
maybe the supermarket and other
The  matics and there are people who
perhaps look first and foremost at
value for money, so say okay
, it’s also important to me how much, so
extremely important how it costs me, of
course, was a holiday home per se and
you’ve got that in all
sorts of things  Crises also noticed, always a
very, very
resilient, so very resistant
business,
always exactly so, people always go on vacation
and in Germany anyway, what
have Corona seen,
hardly any problem actually had earlier in the
preliminary talk, yes, in the end we
hardly had any
problems in that we even in 220
had slightly
better sales than 2019 and but
and with much higher
profitability we were almost almost
break-even in 220 and if
you look at it, of course it was the
year with massive fluctuations, yes,
like we did in April or is it
starting in March March was already under 2
19 April 22 at -9%, so it
only has 10% of our business left  it and
that is of course a situation where you
say
that what is happening now is that we
have executed and managed it very well up to this point
and now we may have problems due to
such an external factor
, especially since we
were in the series defund rising at the time
well, that was
n’t the best time either, of course, and then
it was fine, but in May 2020 I was
only 25% and in 1992 and in June we were
already 100% over 219 again and then of
course the second wave came in winter
or  fall so that in the end, although
there were of course massive wave movements
in 220, but in the end, as I
said, we were actually a little bit better than in
92, many people couldn't believe it,
okay,
so we have to understand now, also from
the financing side, I've got that
then  at Home24 for a while
then you made a decision or you
found one now and the two support
you
and then you immediately got the
financing, we were them  first
investors back then exactly
we um then three of us founded it and
then we had Wolfgang Niesmann were
also managing directors or left
next year now makes
Apollo he Wolfgang is still with
managing directors or now with the board
yes um we
actually almost had that back then  a bit like it
would have been more classic today we
just have a Seat back then there was something like
it was the beginning of 2014 it was
n’t talked about at all, today it would
probably be
divided in a more classic way, but at the beginning we also brought
in business
angels  a little bit of our own money
but above all business angels
um also brought in and then
in the end this song could be
said to be a bit
new German extended so again and
again people with a higher
rating go in but at some
point we can really make big money
exactly  we already started in 2015 to
15 ha  We did serious work with
German funds Munich Ecken capital
and the birth
from London and then in 2016 we had
in Series B inside Venture
Partners from New York, one of the
largest funds in the BC area worldwide and
also the most renowned
and then we got in  became the lead investor
and then later in the series C
um also borrowed
them, they will have done them later in 2017,
then extended again and then
Lexa came along, but also e.g. Rocket, for
example, included a very small part in
particular
, so we plan to
already made more than 200 million before the IPO
and
then with the IPO where we did a
bacon merger, we have
another 250 million going public there
is a special anecdote that you told me in the
preliminary talk, so in the
end if you look at the
Looking at pictures of our IPO, it looks
like we would have done it on the Frankfurt
Stock Exchange and that's it  t relatively expensive
that's not what you think in
Germany you have to pay for being
able to ring the bell in the in the in the
Frankfurt Stock Exchange that was we're going to
phase out
halfway through the phenomenon that was at the end of 22
September 21 well you  could already
you could with a limited number
of employees constantly but still
pay a lot very much
the ringing there a little something yes
we are already talking about 40,000
less you are more in the
entry area okay okay
want to have the picture of how you are standing there with colors
and  so on so I would like to
put it the other way around it has to do it in our
office including the party
for all employees cost less than a
tenth of what it
would have cost us in the stock market okay and what
we did so iconic pictures
too  IPO is to know like at
birth it is only rare once
the willingness to pay is infinite he
takes the B  örse makes full use of it apparently
yes there are enough people who do
it but he had already
mentioned we have we have a
certain way that we don't
see paying for things that we think we can
do better and in this
case it was the same  we didn't
want all the employees we could
n't take all the employees with us, we could take a
limited number with us, even
if you had taken the top package, no matter how much,
and of
course I wanted that from the
oldest employees, namely the
top management, namely yes  just unfair yes
we said not to go to
Frankfurt nobody yes I not for
my ego
to stand there on the floor and ring the bell but what
we did is we have a
video wall such a big video wall in the
office there  built a small desk in
front of it and put a picture
of Deutsche Börse behind it, which was
branded everywhere by ours
Designers everywhere with the home to go
stand then simply rang the bell, yes
, but they also photographed it in such a way that
if you can see it, we
faked it a little, yes, that can be right,
and at the same time we also
built walls with the home to go logo
and so on where you could do that
and funnily enough we also put
hometogo branded trucks in front of the
stock exchange, so
we drove them around the stock exchange,
the city of Frankfurt
kindly also has this pedestrian zone there
with our partner with the  we
did that with the trucks there uh
vacated and then land was really
right in front of the stock exchange big home
to go truck so where because we had
driven around anyway we had our office
drove around several times and also
stood there to say stop  Loud
motor and and and horn then in front of the
stock exchange that also glass we are there although
we did it in Berlin and the company is
currently on the stock exchange  a only
in quotation marks worth 300
million so that means
something has to happen more than
a billion worth
how much money do you need to create what
value now a
lot of money was spent but
you would just have it on the
Keep an account
but it's only a snapshot
unusual that you
invest a lot of money in such projects but that means
the brand doesn't like it, of course
, as I said
, we already said we have it through the market cap or it
's based on the
share price  a snapshot we
have a long-term view on
the topic and the good thing is that
after we did the IPO 22
also in 22 we had to upgrade our Guardians at the end of the
year,
which means in the
end we have more
sales there last year too  already done
when we originally thought when we went public
and this year we have
already done it twice  h have to adjust above because we are
better than they originally thought for the
year and accordingly
operationally we have
done everything we have
promised or even better than we
promised but what is
the position of the investors so what is the stock market doing
I think it's on the one hand
generally probably
every day at the moment company questions that are on the stock exchange
if you look at the
overall market development I think
that's one thing and secondly of
course it's also
quite normal that there's a  It takes a little bit
when you are new to the stock exchange that
people have to gain confidence in the subject
, but I believe that we have taken the
right steps because
you can clearly see that on the
one hand we are not just top line, i.e. what
we see in terms of sales growth and  Sizes of turnover
and
lower loss that we
have delivered on the subjects but also on
our strategic subjects therefore when
you are now looking at Q3, for example,
we just said
strategic issues for us are above
all this business on the marketplace
we call it internal onzeit because you
carry out
the transaction on the platform that’s we’ve grown in q360 percent
but the business is
but has doubled compared to before,
so it has grown 100% in the
period if you then
look at the next strategic topic for us
you these services that we are building
around the marketplace that
has grown almost 250% in Q3 so not only
that the top line numbers are right, but
also where we say strategically, these
are the topics that we
wanted to go into and these are the topics
that we believe in because we believe
that we are giving the market the right
offer, especially from the
technology side  and software side
that it really works, and
uh, I think we're going to
show the market there  that we are
tackling the right issues or
hitting the top line and/or are even
better and at the same time
with the issues that we said these
are our strategically relevant
advances that
underpin them again because they are growing faster
than the business as a whole
you still own a lot in the
company, so we belong to the management,
around seven percent
could be okay, then of course it
's serious money, now it can
quickly be a lot of money, but it's
probably
not that easy for you now, or is it just
because of it  could come I did
n't want to sell it
that's that's I think it's uh the
important thing accordingly it's not
that easy to arrive
either but like that Lock has uPS or something like that we
had lock ups they will
but they've expired a long time ago but if
you sell now  be irritated because
you say okay that too and I
don't want to sell at all I have so-called  ar
still bought yes okay so you think that
you hope and expect and
plan that somehow now again
that he not say no this prepayment
difficult but you do think that
somehow uh the hope
obviously that it is now
developing direction again yes so how  said that is a
snapshot from our point of view we
have
done more than what we
promised yes and that's why
we look at the long-term
value growth because in the end
good business should also be reflected in the share price at some point
and
why you chose this baking variant that
was actually quite interesting we
had so he said earlier we
had in 20 super super yes where many
people still don't understand today
that we are actually just as
good or better than
in 2019 if you put that
I think also because we managed it well
, definitely and that's
why  Of course, at the end of 2020,
Airbnb managed to go public,
and that of course led
to a great deal of interest in us.
Yes, and we just said, he
said at the beginning of his 20s, he wanted to do
the fundraising for me
when Corona was there  is and you - 90%
then of course nobody says oh I
would like to invest
yes and then over the course of the year I saw
how well we performed
and that's why we also understood why
Airbnb is going public yes because of
course that's for you too  made
sense and at the same time we
understood it and that was actually very,
very exciting with the
airbn IPO, how many people were
suddenly interested in us, but
above all, of course,
because the bacon wave started at the same time
, so
we thought about taking a look  let's get started
we'll either do
a private round we'll do an IPO
or maybe bacon vi
Maybe something interesting yes and that was so
crazy for a while that and this
where you gave an interview about it
that he said it's like speed
dating on the roads because you were just
called and she told all kinds of
crazy numbers  what
his company could be worth, just
so that people could go
public and then we just thought about it,
okay, we'll take an investment bank,
look at the overall process,
what are the issues and then
we decided within the framework of this process
decided that we should also look at the
spec site and then we
saw that we had very interesting discussions with the specs
, but it was extremely important for us
that we go together with the spec
and its goals are not just
easy for us to go public  to
gossip in good German and
then to be gone but to find someone
that was also the requirement for us
to fi someone  nd who on the one hand
shares the same topic with us whom we trust and on the other side but also with us what what
reviews and other topics have had a
separate purpose
that is that we are crocheting on the fact that
he repeatedly last year  discussed
here um where a
lot of people invest a shell and
then the shell looks for a daily allowance
and then he gets every ticket
listed somehow then a very
good reward for that
he somehow managed to do it then
out of the  to buy something great with the cave
and then bring it to the stock exchange
um and he did that exactly
and there was above all we could get
much higher ratings from
other specs yes
so what they told us what in the
end got why  Who doesn't
always know, but for us it was just
right to find a partner who
rated us properly and at the same time
also jema  And then a decent incentive
Steam for yourself,
yes,
and we were valued at over 1.2 billion
when we went public
, then yes, it's actually painful for a
company personally anyway,
but also if you then slip out of this
unicorn status, me  I think that
's it now, there are again
conversations about where people actually say
these unicorns are more unicorns,
they just don't have the financial time so they
told and that's good too,
what does it matter if everyone suddenly
sees them or even the employees
The company is only a quarter or a
half or whatever of what
it was yes I think it is of course
essential as a public company like
Siebler yes and I the public markets
also react much faster
you can just look every day
yes  so I think that was one of my
biggest fears that I
look at the share price every day when we
go public thank goodness  it's not
so, uh, I can concentrate very well on the
operative business, which suits
me much better, but in the end it's of
course something that you
have to discuss with the employees
So it's like Siebler or more
transparent with the stock exchange, that
helps but for employees it's actually
incredibly good if you're private,
you probably know there are
these Weser constructions,
i.e. virtual shares that are then issued
, which in the end is a
problem  is because you do
n't have it either, you don't
have it, you don't have it, and with the virtual shares
you always have to have an exit, so
the company has to sell it or list it on the stock exchange
. Only then do you normally get
access to these virtual shares
and then  there is also the
fact that everyone else is served before you
, so the investors you have
eve  nual hurdles that
you have to jump from the valuation and so on
and so forth that's really only on
paper as a public company have
the great advantage that the employees can of
course
convert the shares into shares immediately
and theoretically these shares are immediately
liquid but all the more  it's more like that if
you're
paying for a share now, of course, and then the
value goes down, then of
course all of them are somehow never
negative, of course, the many go, yes, more often,
I can't earn more than adequate
money when you've recovered
, that takes time  years and then let me
rather pay when different are shares
where it goes faster although the price
yes yes but with us we have built the
system that depends on that so
if employees we don't do it
that employees somehow now have a
package for example for
get four years to a certain value yes
but they get every year in the
end
e  A euro amount that is then
converted into shares or with us it is a
package which ultimately consists of
shares and stock options where you can
also take a bit of the
risk but at the same time can also participate more in growth
, so
we also avoid this through these
annual  Allocation we both avoid
issues that you just um
that people maybe haven't been
in the money for too long as you say or
suddenly take absurd heights with them
[music]
in four years the company
share price can be somewhere else so that
's a more serious one  spaqua that's
at least my feeling because one of our
regular guests sits on your supervisory board
and he actually stands for seriousness
and great caution and and thinks
about it we're talking about colleague pipp
Klöckner yes exactly how did you
get on longer we have known him for a long time
yes  also used to be part of
our let me say consultant
team that we used for the
company  So you originally
come from the SEO area, you know better than I do,
yes, we used it
, because ultimately
Wolfgang was a co-founder of the where
you did and tip he used to
do at idealoge, above all,
because I did  they knew each other and uh as
competitors but as respecting the
competitors and that's how a
friendship developed I also got to know him
at work we
said that someone can probably
confirm no matter what you talk to him
you can
always learn something and learn something
That's why I said if we now
get a supervisory board because that's
also the nice thing when you go public
you're Christian
that our
board of directors also includes people where I
would normally go,
yes you could  Exactly, and
for us it was important
that we have a supervisory board that is made up of
people who not only
exercise supervision but who I
would normally also like to have as an
advisor, so there it is
Philipp, yes, then we have a
partner  from Lexa who used to be in the
jungle focus as well Christoph Schuh
then we have a
[music]
auditor yes you also need that
for the topic
and then we have very interesting people
from different areas of
the business who are interesting for
us  have, for example, in Martin
Reiter
who set up Airbnb outside of the
USA, who then managed
Wayfair in Europe,
then we have Susan Sandler,
who used to be responsible for M&A at Booking.com
, then she was Vogel’s right-hand man
the current Booking.com
CEO, who is American, is on
board and then we have Christina
smartley, who was previously a VIP
brand in com  munications at PayPal
recently even now something of its own has been
founded but before that it was still here
in the above Robin Hood also
got how much communication for the
burns for PayPal made as I said
before the Robin Hood film Facebook Messenger
so at Meter super experienced people  and
erm that's fun, yes,
then suddenly it's really a top top
board for the topic and your
goal is, so to speak,
simply further internationalization or to get
even more mental ones in or of
course logically anyway, but where can
you still grow, can you have even more
customers  you are
looking for more holiday homes that you are not
yet getting, or are there
more holiday homes that you have to get on the
platform
in the core markets now, or that's
just opening up new markets, that's
up to us, these are two topics  One, as
I mentioned before, is that
our most developed region, so to speak, is
di  e roof region is then we have a
second region in which we are the rest of
Europe and then North America and exactly in
this order are also
the development stages
exactly that is furthest yes you
then have inventory is then somehow have 20
people houses or 10 or 80
So we are always difficult to say,
but we certainly have 80% of the
holiday homes on the platform
that are relevant for the roof region in
the end, in the end it will be a little less for the rest
of Europe and
even less for the USA, yes, but those are exact  then
these growth topics for us is
above all important on the one
hand what i said at the beginning yes
the marketplace that means
offering the right thing for the customer yes so
we might also let our logo be
seen yes home to go with this dash on the
back yes  That's why
everyone has their own use case and
no, you might
go home to go biking home to go swimming home to go
relax or really to connect your use case
with this with this dash
and for that the prerequisite is that
you first have the largest possible inventory
so that the probability that I
will find the right one for you is
also fulfilled so that is what we
want to offer the customer that  the
customer understands that a classic
holiday home in the
erm not in the city but a
classic holiday home in the
holiday region I have to be at home
first and we are already further along in the roof top market than we are
now in the rest
of Europe and also in North America
Of course there are then, so to speak,
growth opportunities through
internationalization and at the same
time we have this
software and other
service solutions around the marketplace
and that of course also a very
clear growth lever, as I said, we grew
almost 250 percent in Q3, yes we here
where we can see that more and more
Topics we have solved in our
marketplace that w  ir who can actually also
offer wonderfully outside of the marketplace yes and that is of course in
addition to the fact you can
grow geographically another strong
growth lever to ultimately make these
solutions
available to others and
but if they do you have to get the brand
big when booking  airbnbs is a
monster brand is still a crass
brand isn't that a marketing
or then a branding game is in the
end home to simply
in the best case is on the same level as
the two companies I mean then of
course we're talking about companies that are
70 or 80  So it's still worth billions, so that
's a great
opportunity, as I said, in the roof area
, home to go is also much better
known than in the rest of Europe, but
we
still mentioned that at the beginning, yes, we also
have two and three brands because we
also  a bit of a consolidating market
, now we have
Casamundo in Germany, for example  yes,
so bought but from Axel Springer because they
then belonged to Axel
Springer um we bought Domizil this year
another German portal
for holiday homes
Casamundo we didn’t publish
but edomizil a
bit more than 40 million
you also want to continue acquiring in the
end that’s exactly what it is  so who will
next year so our goal is
to be profitable next year and
we have money on the high side
that means
160 and almost 170 okay and then
go shopping and so go shopping
on the one hand where we can
say  we can expand our marketplace
, for example at
edomizil we have now been able to completely replace
our technology with our technology so far within a few months
. Casamundo
runs completely on our
technology  also
old brands so indomiz  ilien Casamundo
are older than us, for example,
and that's why it's of
course also interesting to see how
the different types of customers
interact with these brands and um, of
course we have our main brand
home to go, yes, it's still
exciting from a marketing perspective
to see how these
different brands are
perceived and how they can of
course still position themselves there individually,
yes, Casamundo is certainly a
bit older than the home to go brand now,
also from the
way it is perceived, also from the play of colors
from when  If you look at
the website very simply, it
doesn't mean the approach like Airbnb is supposed to be a
global brand that everyone knows
inevitably no so home to go
is the global burns that we have everywhere
in all markets but we still have in
different markets
sometimes in a second brand
and how is your Mi  development from
performance marketing and and Google
dependency you told
me that there was also a lot to come back then because of Google
but you had such an
abitrate world somehow to buy the traffic
and then say click out to
realize that it was then at best
higher during the  airbn how they
come per se from the brands
will always be
something like what role does google play
then you could really do that now if you do
the marketing if it does something there
so in corona we also partially
identified that you also have the effects a
lot  clearly seen what we were now
almost profitable 20 years ago because the
demand was just there I think
for us there is always a balance where
we have to see how much money we want to
spend on marketing and new
growth because of course you always come back with
new customers  You have customers who also
return and it
was always a strategy for us
to look at the end
result  Talking about SEO, we had made a very
important point that, as I said
, we want to do
SEO again, yes, and we did it at the time
with one of our leading employees,
who actually started a completely new way of SEO for me at the time,
which is now called cultivation and marketing
yes, that we said there is
not some kind of PR and communication
and SEO as individual topics, but there is
an integrated department with data engineers
that is ultimately
designed to be interesting for
the media and thus all media
people
actually based on seometry crap
So when we do PR, for example,
everything is measured by what is how
much how often are we mentioned do we get
the link what is the domainer for it
get the things back and
have been super successful
with this integrated approach, not
just on the  On the opposite side, New
York Tim then comes to us and asks
us for example  l according to you also have
data and the topic has positioned us there as
experts but above
all in the result so if
you know sistrics where you can look at the
visibility for websites
and if you
look at it and it plays yes  also brand
with it is very interesting that,
for example, a home to go alone,
i.e. the home to go.de
domain, is almost three times as large as an
airbnb.de yes in terms of visibility according to
the trick and if we combine our other
domains with Casamundo and  so take it further
you'll
probably get traffic anyway then search
traffic uhm so paid is more like around
50%
meanwhile we invest a
lot in CRM yes so on the one hand
to feed people either via e-
mail or in  to have our app
with push and so on we have over 20
million customers with home to go accounts
it makes you a good cm these days but
that's a question i tried
cases we  Everyone is
talking about counting and everyone says marketing has become
too expensive, so how is it
going for you, that means you look at
what's what, e.g. mechanics
mechanics or ideas in the CM that you
've noticed that work well
there are so  there are essentially two
important marshots in CM how
we divide it yes one is
a bit you can say retargeting
you also know from Pinterest no if you are
currently on Pinterest
somehow you
get the memory right away  what
it might be interesting so yes
exactly if or by post if you do that with
us in the app or also
combined no if the if the
account if
you are logged into the app with your account you will
also get the push in the app if  you on
when you're logged into the website
and so on that's all that links
the one central
one central user profile in effect
and when you j  If you are currently looking for something with us
, we will try to
understand what you find exciting, so we will
send you, for example,
what were you last looking for
if things might be fully booked
, but also say hey there are
topics that might be exciting
for you because you do that
so Rico was able to do
exactly that and the whole thing writes to it
, that's why the
algorithm looks at how you react to it and
so on, so everything is very
automated, we test a lot, but also a
lot manually, but also with machine
learning, which in the end is also  so in
combination also
combination of the CMS works ne of some kind of
destination stories to stories that deal with
objects we know that people
who have a similar search behavior as you
are interested in the things that
could also be interesting for others
so really to look how can I
also segment and I can watch
yes, I think we were d  amals just
a bit so basically
i think the most important thing for us is to
say
we don't have a problem with google per se
yes i think the topic is it
fairer competition than so we
just want that we stand up for the fact that
there should be a holiday competition in general yes
and so  Even before Corona, we
had suggested to the EU Commission that
they take a look at what Google is
actually doing in the travel sector, especially
in the holiday home sector
with its own search implementation,
how they did it for flights, they did
the hotels yes yes Google
probably calls it Google Vacation
Mental Finder based on the Google
Hotel finer yes you see if you
google holiday home then
this onebox as they call it comes in the
results and of course that is something
you basically have to say if you
are a bit
involved  SEO and so on knows that in
the end you usually have the
paid results above  n So where you
pay for google AdWords and then
the organic ones usually come underneath
and google says itself
that in the end the organic
results are ranked according to user
interest, so that they
want to find out and if you then look into SEO to get
up there slowly  work up
you always have to slowly
work up work up work up
and test them are you really relevant for the
user and
the only one who didn't do
it is Google because they simply put their own between
the paid results and the organic
ones and also
also in a I would say very colorful
way, yes, because otherwise you
only have text on the left and they do it with
pictures, cards and so of course a
bit very stimulating to click on it
than maybe a text on the left
and that's just that  which of course is
now a bit problematic from our point of view
if you search horizontally
anyway and g  Especially in Germany with
well over 90 percent market share and
then
you say I would also like to
offer that vertically and actually have the
perfect algorithm to see what
the customer wants, but
still simply put my product in position 0 with the swipe of your finger
above everything else it
costs  certainly cost traffic in SEO,
yes, but in terms of sales, so
whenever traffic goes away,
sales also go away, but it's not like
that, we've grown so well in SEO
through our strategy that we didn't have any
losses as a result, but we
probably just had less growth
yes, so you have to say, and it is
still to be expected in other areas,
so I had now noticed that it
is somehow in yes, yes, I wanted some,
I wanted to from Google, already exist, but
now it's then, then, vacation
rental finder, you have to  First of
all, that's cool. There
aren't any huge markets where you
always have to polish yourself  can i think
google has seen that you for example lost
a lot a lot
on amazon on the product search page and that's why
you probably look at other verticals
very carefully yes i'm
assuming but it's that you
create the destination page immediately  to
become that's too expensive that you can do you
would have to build a brand that
is way too expensive to build up I think
it would be the most elegant thing I also need
a bit of time just no I
always think an Airbnb is, for
example, six years older than us  yes
and a booking built up the
brand essentially with performance
marketing at the beginning yes and I
think it just takes a certain amount of time yes
we have e.g. also quite funny yes we
have we have e.g. as part of
our SEO initiative we also have
sometimes  TV made relatively at the beginning
but also very much as a
bit of a hack in the sense of how
can we do SEO better than can
we can teach Google that space to go is
a top of mind yes that means
we always had this this campaign were
essential so you that we
taught people we need
to go plus a so home to Croatia
hometogo Italy hometogo Baltic Sea and so
further and worked very well
because Google learned even faster
that hometogo is relevant
for you SEO optimization through
TV advertising exactly so people
told us back then
they are already doing TV advertising yes you are still relatively
small we said yes that is  has
more than just TV advertising, so TV
warmth naturally always has a certain brand
effect, yes, because Google has learned that,
okay home to go is simply searched for
tell me, success proves us
right and there are always
funny anecdotes, well, I
also do a lot of business  At
some point one of my companies
approached me when I was like Patrick, um, I was quite
funny, an agency came to us and
said directly that they want to do SEO
and they pitched it so that
as an agency they could do SEO like they do
home to go
yes, really us as a novel
ultimately used we
also won a lot of prizes for how
innovative we did SEO and so
on but that's really exciting
actually
think so
I think I immediately believe that you're good at the game
but if you now  Looks, the
main competitor is Airbnb and that
in the end
you want to get past a Google, so you have to be
in direct type, that's only possible with
a brand,
so are you considering how can
I become that or do you say that
it's slowly developing  or just
step by step or not at all but we
can now you can't educate a brand
because there are already examples
of gorillas and a  Others who have
made it within I
understand other mechanics
behind it but within a short time to be
a brand yes absolutely so I
think um what is important when
you are looking for a holiday home you ca
n’t actually go home to go in
Germany either if  do it in the SCM as
well as once you use it
regardless of that I
think you come you can't get past us in the end
if you're looking for a holiday home
and that's what you say it
takes a certain amount of time to do it
It is also clear that this classic
holiday home booking is not that you do
the topic a year, but
usually do it maybe once or twice
a year, which means that these retention
cycles are of course larger,
but at the same time we see them very
clearly in our Korten above
all  in the roof region, which is
our largest market, like this proportion
of people who have already booked with
us or more than once  ch have booked with
us is increasing so this
repeat is a very strong part of
that of that of the brand topic and we do
too and what we also see is of
course that although we are not doing any
TV advertising or anything like that at the moment
still the of the  the
direct share of the brand
does not suffer from this, yes, and I think that, um,
and in the end we can
see that in the cohorts of
people who booked with us for the first
time and when they come back shows
us that we are exactly on the
There are always the right way, so that's why it's
roof, for example, as a region
within hometogo alone, it's
already profitable because you
see that the customers just
keep coming back there and the proportion
of customers who keep coming back
keeps increasing and that's why  Of course, then
the marketing costs will be lower and
therefore something like roof, you
prefer to do it very analytically than open
now  this somewhat irrational,
unpredictable branding is I'm also asking
a bit because there's been a
fascinating marketing story on the
internet
for many years
off
on vacation and flights and so that's
not exactly your segment now, but
it's also about travel and
they have already managed to be
taken to my household via their internet brand
, so everyone knew at some point
off on vacation but  you can
probably, so everyone can
just go with greener Wolfgang, back
then, just like Zalando or trivago,
yes, I think that was
a different time back then when
you reached more people with TV, first of all with TV
and were also able to scale much more cost-
effectively  because you were there then, too,
so I remember what
I probably mean myself, as
Voo  doo or Zalando
started with TV there was hardly any
internet advertising yes in real TV that
means you got a lot more out of it
the TV stations might
not have fully understood the mechanics it
was much easier back then
but it is now too
another game no you then somehow
have that somehow Youtube you have a
tiktok what all sorts of different
channels these are relevant
channels in that we also record them
yes but now it is nothing
that is of course somehow comparable to
the Google search yes but that  it's
not really a big issue for you
we look at everything I think that
's what you have to do we keep
testing and you've already
mentioned we're very data-
driven, so we're also very, so in
general I think we're very  economical
than as a company so having a
brief preliminary talk about
how we equip our office is
wonderful  it's office but for
example always themed rooms and
the employees work in these themed rooms because they
're just up for it themselves,
so a room is somehow called Bergheim
because it doesn't have any windows in it exactly or
we have um
Miami art deco yes we have the
treehouse  Beach House, we
would say
created rooms, yes, of course we pay for
it, but so to speak, we
have not hired an interior design company
for a few million to make it
look hip, but it is real and
it connects the employees
with the company in an incredible way, which is always
extreme to me  what is important is that we take it, e.g. even
if we move to a new office, we
always take all our old furniture with
us and say how can we use it again in the
best possible way, how can we
use it again and not just
something we can do, what can we do
new, just new  do yes and I
think both from the system about
thoughts but also from the
spar  Thoughts of sociability is always something
that is a bit built into
hometogo yes and
yes I think that's why we would
n't spend absurd amounts of money now
to push the brand through
and can you go to the USA, he wanted to,
you just said that's it  now you
can hold your own against the really big
play there you can always hold your own if
you have a good offer and I think
what distinguishes home to go is,
above all, on the one hand, of
course, the largest offer in the
holiday home holiday apartment
market  traveller's point of view on the other
hand, but above all
in the end it is the best or the best
way for our
partners who provide us with inventory
to get bookings,
yes, we are, for example, so that we do
n't just get our partners through
Technology help but also say
we are more flexible in
terms of your cancellation issues, for example
ng conditions in terms of topics
such as how we do which payment
methods we offer and so on, so
we give
many of our partners more
freedom to communicate with the customer, which is
incredibly helpful for the partner and ultimately also helps the
customer because he always has a
direct contact person
and from that we can already see that we are from
our point of view we do a lot of things
differently than now a classic
classic portal yes we come
from a different history we
have this marketplace that still
has this advertising element if you like
that if you like that  so want to say where
these
click-outs take place and
we give the customers I say hey you only have
to on the home to go marketplace so
our inventory partners you can only
use us on the home to go marketplace
but also outside we give you
the  Opportunities to use the things,
which in the end is of course
also exciting for many inventory partners, ne die
Say hey, um,
can I use the service
?
yes I would
say great rating I mean that is
the most attractive business marketplace
to be but the question is is you
really one or are you still
in the situation that you somewhere
abitrat then stocked the marketplace yourself
through through through yes exactly when
you look globally, around 50% of
our transactions are on the marketplace,
so around 80% are no longer most developed in the marketplace
in Germany
.  and Germany was
just a few years ago lower so
that means it keeps growing this
area is also growing the fastest as
I said has doubled compared to last
year when I look at the
traveled sales compared to
2018 that takes place on the marketplace
he has  20 watts ago yes the one on the
market since 2018
has grown much faster than any other
segment and if I now look around
with our further positioning
yes that we say we
have other services that
are ultimately interesting for our marketplace providers
not only on the
marketplace but also outside of the
marketplace where a lot of things are done via
subscription nasty yes so
classic SARS business you have a
completely different opportunity of course
to position yourself to work with the
partner but
at the same time of course to explain the market
what is actually special
is because in the end we have egg  n
classic
in German would probably say
flywheel so in English flywheel
like marketplace is built between
demand and supply and at the same
time this accelerator software and
other service solution around the marketplace
it is actually conceivable that
companies like Airbnb or booking say
people do that now  the guys are really good
, they're also very good at something technically
and somehow we managed to get the whole
inventory on there now they
currently cost 300 million marketing
- they still have 160 somehow or 170
cash so the net costs are actually
only 130 million that's for  these
companies at Portokasse tell me and then
say I'll take them with me first, I
need them with me, then it'll
soon be called somehow Airbnb vacation
rentals and zack uh, so there's a
consideration that you have a bigger one
than with that too, nobody has
contacted you
So of course I can't comment on that either
yes it is and in case of doubt
regardless of whether someone has
reported or not yes I say if you are
now very on the other side
then you will logically think about
what he heard I sell I sell
I do not sell my shares I
think we have  a very good
deal and accordingly with the
knowledge on the other side
I would certainly also
want to look at home to go yes but um as
I said
for the old employer i.e. for
Home24 um there it was furniture I noticed
um there it was  just recently xxlutz from austria handed out
to very good
company will implement who said
okay now i'll take myself by 14 cm so there
may be someone if
they don't have to be anymore
basically yes as
i said i way of thinking i conceivable is always a
lot  Yes, I think in the end I think,
just like us as home to go, we look at a lot of
things in the market that could be interesting for us
consolidate or buy it will
certainly other providers
we will do very briefly but on the open letter
you can't react to the letter from
but also good so Google yes
then not yes then you
just said you are making a
few investments yourself  are there the top 1 2
investments you have erm top 1 2 well
I have
that is certainly a very good
investment then tour lane
travel area clearly I have a
lot of affinity for it and one thing
I know about it I’ve heard that it
one thing they do in the end
easams as 1 Stripes solution so that
you can simply install ISMS as an API in your system
yes so payment no um
really for then for your phone
you can theoretically do about it but in the
end provide an API to make it
available  ah okay so SIM card exactly
so electronic SIM card that I can
send you with a code and then
you can just install it like that
you don't have to take anything physically anymore,
that's of course exciting for all
kinds of topics, so if
you have wearables, for example watches or
something like that, or you have a large fleet of
e.g
a lot so there I invested very early is
a good friend of mine I am women
in the investor with right at the beginning
and since now at the
whycam kombinator is now CEO
of U-Bahn invests the nimble guys
and co from there Dash and so on okay
okay everything already three things
you always do so probably I'm going to assume
50,000 tickets or something depends
yes well that's definitely
around it yes okay well the expansion is
now somehow outside of the roof and
is from the USA and um yes for you for the
Colleagues Klöckner who probably has
a few shares of your order is
the supervisory board in Germany
exactly
curious whether that is now  somehow
soon from 300 million look again at
once so
unicorn then we have to be happy next round
all right thank you
very much you are very welcome Ciao bye